[Musique]
là bas les pattes
c'est une religion c'est le premier plat
qu'on mange tous les jours à midi
c'est le plat principal des italiens il
ya plein de types de pâtes des pâtes
farcies comme les raviolis les pattes
longue comme les spaghettis les bugatti
nil et talia tels les pappardelle et les
chiens la télé des pâtes courtes comme
les penne les farfal l'erika johnny
[Musique]
là on a déjà la thalie et elles viennent
de la côte amalfitaine
ce sont des tailles est elle plus courte
et plus fine et l'est pas par des leçons
napolitaine se sont détaillés tel film
est plus large
[Musique]
je suis en train de préparer des
stratégies nati avec de la farine de
l'eau du sel et après je fais reposer la
pâte pendant 30 minutes après ces trente
minutes
j'en fais des petites rondelles je les
coupe tous les trois centimètres après
avec trois doigts je vais créer la forme
de la pâte
il ya un trou à l'intérieur du coup
quand je vais les faire revenir avec la
sauce les pattes vont prendre leur goût
j'ai fais cuire les brocolis dans de
l'eau salée la même eau de cuisson que
les pâtes échalotes
une fois que c'est doré j'ajoute de la
saucisse fraîche et puis j'ajoute les
brocolis
[Musique]
d